el mundo actual requiere de manera
urgente acciones transformativas que
apunten a sostener la vida de todo el
planeta la pregunta es como como el
logro a partir de mis acciones
individuales transformar el entorno que
me rodea yo creo en algo creo que la
sociedad se transforma gracias a la suma
de acciones individuales también creo en
el poder que tienen las personas para
transformarse y transformar y es por
esto que he investigado y buscado formas
para resolver ese como esto me ha
llevado a descubrir dos claves muy
poderosas lo que hice fue unirlas y
organizar una estrategia
que aplicó en todos los aspectos de mi
vida cotidiana
esas dos claves son sentir pensar y
conectar
desde muy pequeño nos enseñaron que el
mundo está ordenado y empezamos a
conocer club por partes
nos dijeron esto es economía esto es
política esto es sociología esto es un
grupo social y este es otro y aprendimos
que el mundo tenía fragmentos y que
había límites muy marcados dentro de
ellos incluso en las ciencias abordamos
las problemáticas por disciplinas
hablamos de química de biología de
antropología y de sociología y eso ha
funcionado muy bien hasta el momento
porque lo que nos ha permitido avanzar
en ciencia tecnología y medicina entre
otros gracias a esos tenemos sistemas de
potabilización de agua marcapasos
materiales resistentes y un sinnúmero de
ejemplos más
sin embargo en la era actual parece que
hace algo para llenar esos fragmentos
parece que las problemáticas no encajan
en uno solo de esos cuadros y la
pregunta que surge ahora es que está
haciendo la humanidad para llenar esos
vacíos la respuesta es simple la
humanidad se está conectando las
conexiones permiten la transformación
del mundo
es muy conocido por todos que amstetten
es la capital de la bicicleta porque la
bici es el principal medio de transporte
en esta ciudad
no siempre fue así en esta ciudad el
estado ha priorizado el carro y un
proceso histórico para que llegaran a la
bicicleta como es un principal medio de
transporte cuando estudias este proceso
de cerca te das cuenta que la clave que
usaron fue las conexiones sí
en esta ciudad el gobierno se conectó
con las necesidades de las comunidades
de sus ciudadanos y permitió crear
políticas que favorecían el uso de la
bicicleta de igual manera el sector
privado se conectó con esta nueva ola de
necesidades y permitió generar un
mercado que transformará este sistema de
movilidad hoy en día sabemos que migrar
hacia formas sostenibles de movilidad es
prioritario porque la calidad del aire
el deterioro de la calidad del aire está
causando más de 4.4 millones de muertes
anuales según la mesa' ahora hay muchos
países que quieren entrar en esta onda
de la movilidad sostenible y cuál va a
ser la clave para lograrlo conexiones se
necesita una comunidad empoderada con
conocimiento se necesita un sector
público y gubernamental que conecte con
esas necesidades de la comunidad y que
está dispuesto a resolverlas
igualmente se necesita un sector privado
que abra mercado y que permita
transformación pero también es
importante saber que las soluciones que
aplican en una parte del mundo
necesariamente en otra
y la academia debe generar soluciones y
adaptarse a esos contextos nuevos esas
conexiones son extremadamente
importantes para poder transformar
por otra parte
como hago para aplicar las conexiones en
mi vida hay algo llamado el pensamiento
complejo el pensamiento complejo es una
habilidad mental o más bien un conjunto
de habilidades es como si tuviéramos
nuestro tema de interés nos alejáramos
ccoo y empezáramos a hacer una vista
panorámica de la problemática de esa
manera empiezan a aparecer todos los
fragmentos implicados y lo que debe
empezar a hacer es a conectarlas el
pensamiento complejo es como los
músculos se entrena se construye se
practica cualquiera puede tenerlo y
empieza con una simple pregunta la que
sea un ejemplo si yo tengo un quebranto
de salud y me hago la pregunta cómo
mejoro mi salud y mi respuesta es voy a
tomar x medicamento es muy probable que
los síntomas disminuya pero no las
causas si lo que quiero es una verdadera
transformación de mi salud tengo que
hacer el alejamiento empezar a ver todos
los fragmentos implicados tengo que
reconocer que mi salud depende de mis
hábitos alimenticios de mis rutinas de
ejercicios
de las prácticas a las que me sumo de
mis hábitos diarios que depende de
muchos factores y hasta que no actúe
sobre todos estos fragmentos no habrá
una verdadera transformación el
pensamiento complejo aparece cuando
empiezo a reconocer toda esa realidad y
actuar sobre todas ellas
aparece cuando veo la salud no como solo
una cosa sino como un conjunto de ellas
y empiezo a actuar en el todo pero la
salud sólo un ejemplo puedo aplicar este
principio a cualquier problemática de la
vida cotidiana a las finanzas oa
cualquier problema que se les ocurra
siempre empiecen con una pregunta
cualquiera no tiene que hacer la
pregunta más elaborada empiece con una
pregunta simple y luego aléjense y
busquen todos los fragmentos y las
conexiones que puede haber entre ellos
el pensamiento complejo transforma a
través de la renovación de nuestra mente
vamos a la segunda clave sentí pensar es
un concepto muy bonito que se está
estudiando fuertemente en la academia y
uno de sus primeros ponentes el
sociólogo orlando cuenta que lo aprendió
de un campesino colombiano luego él y
otros científicos y pensadores como
arturo escobar lo han desarrollado
estudiado ampliado hasta construirlo
como un concepto que hoy en día es
fundamental en la investigación en
ciencias ambientales para mí sentir
pensar es clave para transformar y lo
que empecé a preguntarles como cómo
puede usar este concepto y la sabiduría
que representa para transformar mi
entorno y por extensión el planeta
tomemos la ciencia y llevémoslo a la
práctica
y tengo que empezar por reconocer que no
podemos resolver las problemáticas
solamente desde nuestra razón la mayoría
de veces intentamos resolverlas con
lógica y razón y olvidamos un componente
esencial en nuestra humanidad el sentir
el sentir tiene que ver con nuestras
emociones y con nuestra intuición
se acuerdan de lo de alejarse para poder
ver los fragmentos y que al conectarlos
íbamos a poder transformar pues cuando
sentí pensamos podemos ver más
fragmentos que cuando solo pensamos y
escuchen esto entre más fragmentos
logremos ver más conexiones podremos
hacer y por tanto mayor poder de
transformación tendrán nuestras acciones
las emociones son reales las
neurociencias tienen muy bien estudiados
los mecanismos bioquímicos que generan
las emociones y también está comprobado
que hemos y comprendemos el mundo a
través de nuestros sentidos es por esto
que es tan importante que nuestras
acciones transformativas incluyan
nuestro sentido
recuerden sentir pensar esta pregunta
simple desde donde arranca todo
debe arrancar o debe surgir no solamente
el pensamiento sino que debe surgir
también desde nuestro sentido
entonces en la práctica cuando aplicamos
el sentido a nuestras preguntas no están
solos enfocadas en el hacer sino también
en el ser el sentir y pensar llama la
empatía al reconocimiento de los otros
como iguales a valorar lo humano y lo
humano hagamos un ejercicio de nuevo
aplica para cualquier tópico de nuestras
vidas voy a dar un ejemplo concreto en
la crianza que necesita un ser humano en
sus etapas tempranas de desarrollo una
respuesta desde el pensar podría ser
alimento abrigo limpieza límites para
que cuando involucramos involucramos
nuestro sentir aparecen en la escena
factores mucho más allá de sus
necesidades básicas aparece el abrigo el
apego los gestos las palabras bonitas el
tiempo de calidad
muchos de ellos intangibles pero
extremadamente necesarios para el
adecuado desarrollo de un infante y la
ciencia cada día lo comprueba
cuidar la salud mental de un bebé es tan
importante como cuidar la salud mental
de un adulto si sentí pensamos la
crianza vamos a transformar el mundo y
de nuevo esto es sólo un ejemplo pero se
puede hacer el ejercicio con cualquier
cuestión de nuestras vidas y saben una
cosa
el globo entero está apropiando esas
estrategias de transformación hoy en día
las grandes multinacionales hablan de
co-creación que no es más que trabajar
de la mano del cliente y más allá de eso
sentir sus necesidades empatizar con
ella en ciencia e incluso a nivel
gubernamental en muchos países se habla
del diálogo de saberes que es poner
sobre la mesa los saberes científicos
comunitarios y ancestrales y conectarlos
a través de la sensibilización del
sentir para mí sentir pensar y conectar
para transformar se ha convertido en una
estrategia que aplicó en todas las áreas
de mi vida personal y profesional la
aplicó en todos los proyectos donde
participó en escenarios nacionales e
internacionales y ha sido muy bien
recibida recuerden que todo empieza con
algo
simple como la intención de hacerlo les
aseguro que apostar por esta estrategia
no sólo cambiará su vida profesional
sino que impactará sus vidas personales
y en la suma de todos esos cambios
individuales el mundo se transformará de
manera positiva sentir pensar y conectar
para transformar gracias